magnus says the draw's the same as a  loss i'm going to play on for the win  but  magnus he knows he's losing he improves  his bishop but um  simply the black queen stepping forward  checking the white king  how is that going king gonna escape now  the black rook will drop down  checking the vikings yeah the king is  never going to escape and so  i mean at the very least it's going to  be a draw and a draw is enough to  go through wesley makes the draw yeah  and wesley's the champion wesley  is the winner of the oprah euro rapid  the second time  he wins an event in the melt water  champions chess draw and the second time  he beats the world champion magnus  carlsen in the final  what a success for the fantastic